the storm had escalated to severe we
have no choice but to abort the mission
I'm Ridley Scott the director of Martian
and for me a few other films that you've
heard I think I landed first on real
dystopia you got to move on you got to
move forward because that Martian was
more optimistic viewer thought was kind
of interesting I like the dry humor like
the gallows humane joke about nearly
having died I'm entering this log for
the record and I'm still alive
obviously NASA looked toward the landing
on Mars in 2025 maybe 2030 in the
Martian that's why everything slightly
futuristic but not a lot I mean the
suits look like they could be today the
ship is an evolution of fundamentally
the International Space Station because
once you're up there you don't need
aerodynamics because it's a vacuum if
I'd known about Martian water which we
now believe to be salt or brackish that
may have affected the story a little bit
he would have actually been trying to
work out how the hell'd I took brackish
water into drinking water it would be
pity to have lost the sequence where he
blows himself up Mars right now is about
eight months then eight months back so
it's impractical right now at the moment
they've just evolved what they call a
plasma engine so you might change a
journey to Mars from eight months down
to three months four months does that
mean a journey to the next planet is not
impossible there's a lot of reasons why
I think it's important to go to Mars to
spend that kind of research intense
research and planning because the
teachers are something every time we do
something is monumental is that it's
monumental and that learning curve could
evolve into all kinds of information and
the fact they now know there's salt
water on Mars that will tell them a lot
was they go into the water
what evolve there how
evolve was mars-like here if Mars is
like here long ago are we heading in
that direction Mars now is the stepping
stone off into what I call deep water
because once you're beyond Mars you're
gonna go into deep space where you have
to come to terms with flying close to
the speed of light there will be people
who will be definitely willing to go off
into space never return for sure
probably gonna list now half a million
people say I'll do it actually no way
but I wouldn't need to I've just done it